today we're going to be speaking with
David Auerbach who's a writer and
technologist and author of Mega Nets how
digital forces beyond our control
commandeer our daily lives and inner
realities maybe to start with David when
we talk about Mega Nets what what do you
mean by Mega Nets what are some examples
yeah I think the other question you want
to ask is why a new word and the key
aspect is that I wanted a term that not
only includes these huge networks uh by
which I include everything from social
networks to online games to
cryptocurrencies
um but to emphasize that the people and
the data we put into these networks are
now an intrinsic part of it that we're
accustomed to thinking of these networks
as things that we program that Engineers
program and come up with and and we're
just subjected to them but that's not
really what's happening what's happening
is we have these systems that now are
engaged in feedback loops very high high
volume high velocity and uh High
virality feedback loops that constantly
cause their own algorithms and behavior
to change so that you can't step into
the same algorithm twice so to speak
and my argument that I make in the book
is that these particular kinds of
systems which I call meganets
um don't
let us have control in the way that we
think we use it we in the way that we
think we do or the way that we used to
over software that in fact they are
becoming more akin to Natural systems
like you know the weather or plate
tectonics or even something like
macroeconomics where you can exert some
push on it but asking say to okay let's
just stamp out everything bad on the
Internet is like saying well let's just
Stamp Out All stock crashes yeah when we
um uh when we think about some of those
feedback loops and algorithms I mean
just to take something simple like much
of the social media we interact with I
think in in passing casual layperson
terms many of us sort of understand that
these algorithms are optimized for
keeping us on the platform as well as
generating engagement and that
engagement is more likely to be
generated by content that triggers a
bigger emotional reaction and so that
that's where we get a lot of these Echo
chambers of extremist content and things
that titillate and so on and so forth we
kind of think we have this passing
understanding sort of of what's
happening but there's more to it right
and I think this is part of what you get
to in the book that there's a whole
other layer that goes beyond that
understanding
yeah because what happens is that
um you know that focus on engagement
certainly there's a financial incentive
there but some of it is also that
um these algorithms are effectively run
out of control it's not as though
someone at Facebook is making the choice
for engagement every single time the
algorithms are being tweaked and shunted
so that you know often based on wrong
information even because you know there
are no way infallible what you get is
um is our our forces that uh that that
do amplify popular content but also
forces that cause uh balkanization and
mutual incomprehension uh simply because
yeah there is that catering towards
what's termed engagement and the focus
on engagement isn't I mean yes profit is
there but it's also well what would you
substitute for it because at that point
well now the uh now the tech companies
are telling you what you want engagement
sort of became the default uh the
default rationale for what to show
people because anything else is okay the
tech companies are now running our lives
so if Facebook puts a you know a warning
on a piece of content saying this is
misinformation well okay that's not
optimizing for engagement but you've
caused a different problem at that point
there are many um yeah no go ahead
yeah the issue is that even if you were
to have to be able to make those sorts
of decisions in a way that wouldn't
cause massive uh controversy you still
have the issue that there's more content
that can be possibly be filtered
certainly ahead of time you're
constantly closing the Barn Door after
the horse is bolted and that's why when
misinformation by one cent or another
gets out it's very hard to change
people's minds because the nature of
these Mega Nets is that you can now find
reinforcing data for whatever Viewpoint
you have and that's really what's
changed is that you have these
many-to-many networks and it's not even
a matter of killing brush fires so much
is that it's creating once you have a
surplus of content and no evolutionary
pressure to to sort of select one
narrative that everybody then sort of
falls into then there's there's no Force
driving people to reconcile and you know
you can't do much to to to bring people
together around a an enforced narrative
so along those lines you know often the
idea of we need more regulation is
thrown around and whether folks even
know what they really mean by that when
they say it isn't totally clear
sometimes there's a sort of these
companies have gotten too big and they
need to be broken up and that will
improve the situation but it's not
exactly totally clear how uh Jonathan
height has mentioned like one thing that
would be useful at the individual user
level would be uh you can't be anonymous
to the platform you can use a handle
that's not your real name but you should
genuinely have to sort of like register
with the social media platform so they
know who you are but a lot of people are
like I don't know that I necessarily
want every social media platform having
my driver's license I don't know some of
the things you suggest are kind of
counter-intuitive can you talk a little
bit about what you think would help
yeah well I think that you know one of
the reasons why people are having such a
hard time coming with fixes is that we
don't understand the problem that well
we don't understand the limits of our
control that if if you're going to
regulate the first impulse is to say
okay just like get rid of everything I
don't like
and
um and it's put the tech companies into
a weird position because they are they
do is more or less safe now and again
that they literally don't have the
amount of control that they that we
think they do and that they often claim
to because you know there's a there's
this Facebook memo where they they're
more concerned about being uh seen as
not having control of their own systems
that is being perceived as evil like
better that they'd be evil capitalists
and that they literally be out of
control but unfortunately the latter one
is a lot closer true so my suggestions
are you know I guess they're they're
meant to
um try to sort of break up the
Tendencies of these Mega Nets by uh uh
by by decoagulating the pockets that
tend to amplify stuff and what I have in
mind here you know in the run-up to the
2020 election Facebook banned all
political advertising right that's not
the action of a company that can like
you know make a fine-grained filtering
of content so I take that as admission
there okay now there's no question that
did uh that I'm sure that did have an
effect
um uh was it over the top Maybe
but uh it's that sort of level that we
actually can't operate on and the
question is how do you do those sorts of
interventions without it uh interfering
in people's freedoms and without it
um and without it coming off as biased
so that's why I advocate for
non-targeted mechanisms where you aren't
really trying to Target a particular
type of content Because unless it's
something really extreme like child
pornography that's okay to Target I
think we all agree that that stuff can
be removed from the net but
when it comes to you know sort of stuff
that's uh in the quote-unquote
mainstream of political discourse well
the mainstream now includes pretty much
each side thinking that the other side
is evil so you're not going to win on
that one what you can do instead though
is try to amplify
um diversity and
um and the quieter voices in other words
enforce something like turn taking where
basically the louder you get the less
privilege you have to be heard in the
algorithm or say intentionally
randomized recommendation algorithms so
you get things that are not what's being
recommended to you Tick Tock apparently
did this with uh
pro-anorexia videos because they were
recommending two pro-anorexia too many
pro-anorexia videos to that crowd so
they actually broke down the
recommendation algorithm and said okay
start giving them other stuff no matter
what it is just stop giving them the
reiterations of what they already have
and targeting something specific
like a particular type of content means
you're always going to be chasing after
the next one but if you were to be if
you were to do this more generally
speaking and not say look we're not
Banning this we're just going to say
that there's going to be a more you know
egalitarian uh float of what you see and
who gets to speak I think you could move
in a bit in a better Direction now that
isn't to say that you would have to not
you have to do experiments here you have
to make sure that it is fair and not
corrupt and all of that but I do think
that those sorts of solutions are more
feasible than the ones we look to now
where effectively we're saying oh just
go in and audit the algorithms and
eliminate bias and you know do what we
want that's life to me is a non-starter
it seems that to some degree a lot of
these discussions that have to be had
about how to fix this problem that we
don't yet 100 percent understand but
we're hopefully building a picture of
what the problem is it seems a lot of
this would be mitigated by greater media
literacy and critical thinking skills
which which generally speaking seem to
be lacking now I don't want to pretend
like that's just the solution that if
people were smarter because you're sort
of saying like all these stupid people
are making us have to figure out this
sort of thing I I don't want to say that
but at the same time when I see in my
space some of the narratives that end up
having to be fought and that then you
have to figure out policy on or they
lead to what some then say is censorship
or whatever if we had on average
greater critical thinking and media
literacy skills it seems as though that
would be useful even though I don't want
to just say the problem is stupid people
it's interesting I mean from my
perspective I mean maybe I was one of
the stupid people because a lot of the
stuff wasn't on obvious to me and one of
the things I talk about in the book is
you know I I worked at Google I was a
software engineer in the early days and
I don't think any of us anticipated the
degree of impact that people would have
that the users would have
um it just it just it was just not an
obvious thing we were so used to saying
okay well here's the data and we do
stuff with it not oh users are coming in
and they're shaping the algorithms so I
I think part of the problem is is that
um
is that even very smart people it's not
an obvious system
um and I don't claim to understand at
all and it took you know it took quite a
bit of thinking for me to sort of get my
head around what I thought was actually
going on because even the really smart
people I knew seem to be falling into
various cul-de-sacs uh partly I think as
an effect of being reinforced in this or
that thought by being by getting placed
into these little balkanized uh uh
they're not they're not just bubbles
they're like narrative bunkers where the
assumptions become so
taken for granted that you can never get
past them so I actually I'm not I think
that the level of thinking required is
actually beyond that which individuals
can easily get a hold of because I mean
I had I had I had a lot of time to do it
and I still I still am not certain about
it that and one of the points I make is
that there's just too much that this
explosion of data and information I
think is moving the unit of agency
higher so that individual rationality
doesn't work and doesn't have the same
efficacy that it used to a gang is gonna
a gang of people a group of people is
going to be able to out out shout in
these networks any individual no matter
what their
um no matter how how great their
um
their
their critical thinking may be there are
exceptions you know if you're Donald
Trump obviously you have more pull if
you're Jeffrey Hinton you know one of
the founders of deep learning as it
exists today you know that that will
count for something but in the main I
think
um
the application of critical thinking I
think it leads to a sense of
powerlessness and of uncertainty of
flip-flopping between well
uh there's that there's those groups of
people over there that literally don't
even have the same language or
foundations for their thought that I do
how on Earth do I even resolve that that
it's sort of it's it's super rational in
that in that
um it's too big for one person or even a
company to get its uh to get its head
around and I don't mean to be fatalistic
about that but you know it echoes the
current concerns with AI that you know
AI is not intelligent per se but it does
have a capacity to
incorporate these huge amounts of data
in the way that we don't and that's one
of the reasons why we can't exactly tell
what's going on with it and I mean even
again very look at they're very smart
people who I think are completely wrong
about what AI is capable of or what it
does you know to me these new chat Bots
they do not think they do not understand
what they're saying to me I think that
is absolutely a um indisputable but
um you know there are people with more
expertise in it than I do that insist
that that's not the case and I don't
think any amount of critical thinking is
going to resolve that you need something
that's sort of like structurally just
prevents chaos from forming last thing I
want to ask you about do you have an
opinion about and if you don't that's
fine what's been going on with Twitter
recently uh DeSantis launch failure
aside in terms of you know I have found
that even though I didn't I at no point
have decided I'm sick of Twitter and I'm
getting off of it but slowly since Elon
Musk took over you know they took away
my and many other people's verification
and
um we're now looking at my verified feed
does nothing for me it shows me people
with 30 followers who are paying eight
bucks a month for some reason and how
all power to them but that's not the way
I was using that before that was a
useful tool for me the for you feed is
even though I'm a person on the left
it's feeding me right wing stuff from
Bridget Gabriel and other right-wing
bomb throwers so that's not interesting
to me my following feed where I see the
people I'm actually following
is quite dead because many of those
people also have reduced their usage of
Twitter what do you have an opinion
about what's happening on Twitter
um I mean not an informed one since I
don't have a huge I don't have much in
the way of sources on the inside but
um I think it's a combination of intent
and incompetence I mean you know
um even even if they were even if they
supposedly fired their worst performing
50 there was still a brain drain there
you know that that that that that that
musk's track record is of going in
shaking things up just blowing things up
and then sort of forcing people to
reassemble it
um the problem is is that it's okay if
you do that you know if you do that to a
private company no one no one's going to
notice except the employee and employees
and maybe you know the stock market or
whatever if you do it on Twitter you're
gonna see the theme showing so for any
of these
phenomena that you're talking about some
of them may be uh partly or wholly
intentional but I have no doubt that a
lot of it is just sheer chaos that
they're they're struggling you know he
brought in
um uh he brought in uh that assistant
who slept on the floor she was gone a
month later uh and it sounds like you
know I I the his new CEO appointment
seems like a scapegoat to me so uh all
right so
um if you have a more specific question
I can say but I do think that in some
ways Twitter was all always a very
anomalous entity in that it didn't make
it didn't especially make money
um it was run worse because it didn't
make money it was run worse than a lot
of the other big networks
um it was a massive Target because of it
being a Public Square the target for
everybody
and so
um I it was never I don't think it was
ever going to end well it didn't happen
have to end with uh in this particular
way with us buying it but you know there
was a reason why uh there weren't any
competing bids it's it is very much a
poison chalice and in some ways I do
suspect that the very idea of a Central
Public Square is on the way out because
um
it it's tat it was becoming basically
impossible for it to keep people happy
enough people happy
um now musk sort of as the
accelerationist option yes very much
Happy we could make people
um you know my my Twitter experiences
I mean it's a I've run into some of the
same problems but
um
I think because of the way I curate my
feed it's probably hit me a little less
but I can I can see the decline
um uh and uh
and again I mean
some of these are definitely bugs and
there's definitely a chance that the
thing I mean I've seen weird bizarre
things popping up and it's like okay
that's got to be a bug I don't get what
that is the fact that we can't totally
tell I guess is an interesting part of
the uh part of the whole thing well the
weird thing is is that I mean that I
think that's always been the case it's
just become much more noticeable yeah
you know I think you know Facebook
thought I was black for many years it
might still
um and if I knew that I could see why
some of the ads I was getting it's like
oh okay that's that's why
um but you know and I'm pretty sure that
wasn't intentional but you know the job
of the company is to keep it from
becoming too obvious yeah Twitter's
problem right now is that it's become
pretty obvious very much so very much so
the book is Mega Nets how digital forces
beyond our control commandeer our daily
lives and inner realities we've been
speaking with the book's author David
Auerbach David really appreciate your
time and insights today
great okay uh thank you for having me